[Music]  duct tape and Crisco helps wanna know  the Academy of Country Music Awards  always bring out the best in fashion and  this year was no exception tell me about  your draft it's Alexander McQueen I'm  lucky Nicole Kidman dazzled in this long  sleeve creation as did Savannah Chris  Lee who went super sexy in a super  revealing black gown it's Monique  Lhullier she's known for wedding dresses  and I feel like since I'm like in the  spirit of like getting marrieds there  and I shouldn't do this bride-to-be  Kelsea Ballerini brought a burst of  spring to the carpet while Miranda  Lambert looked white-hot in a plunging V  ensemble alongside her man Anderson East  [Music]  Carrie Underwood shimmer did a nude  gowns with tons of crystal  embellishments later she hit the stage  in a bold metallic number that showed  off her slim waistline and signature  toned legs so many stunning looks which  one is your favorite tweet us your pic  at UT now  [Music]  you